so I'd like you to imagine for a moment
that you're a soldier in the heat of
battle
maybe you're a Roman foot soldier or a
medieval Archer or maybe you're a Zulu
warrior regardless of your time and
place there are some things that are
constant your adrenaline is elevated and
your actions are stemming from these
deeply ingrained reflexes reflex is
rooted in a need to protect yourself and
your side and to defeat the enemy so now
I'd like you to imagine playing a very
different role that of the scout so the
scouts job is not to attack or defend
the scouts job is to understand the
scout is the one going out mapping the
terrain identifying potential obstacles
and the scout may hope to learn that say
there's a bridge in a convenient
location across a river but above all
the Scout wants to know what's really
there as accurately as possible and in a
real actual army both the soldier and
the scouter essential but you can also
think of each of these roles as a
mindset a metaphor for how all of us
process information and ideas in our
daily lives and what I'm going to argue
today is that having good judgment
making accurate predictions making good
decisions is mostly about which mindset
you're in so to illustrate these
mindsets in action I'm going to take you
back to 19th century France where this
innocuous-looking piece of paper
launched one of the biggest political
scandals in history it was discovered in
1894 by officers in the French General
Staff and it was torn up in a waste
paper basket but when they pieced it
back together they discovered that
someone in their ranks had been selling
military secrets to Germany so they
launched a big investigation and their
suspicions quickly converged on this man
Albert Dreyfus he had a sterling record
no past history wrongdoing no motive as
far as they could tell but Dreyfus was
the only Jewish officer at that rank in
the Army and unfortunately at this time
the French army was highly anti-semitic
so they compared Dreyfus his handwriting
to that on the memo and concluded that
it was a match even though outside
professional handwriting experts were
much less confident in the similarity
but never mind that they went and
searched Dreyfus apartment looking for
any signs of espionage they went through
his files and they didn't find anything
and this just convinced them more the
Dreyfus was not only guilty but sneaky
as well because clearly he had hidden
all of the evidence before they had
managed to get to it
next they went and looked through his
personal history for any incriminating
details they talked to his teachers they
found that he had studied foreign
languages in school which clearly showed
a desire to conspire with foreign
governments in later in life
his teachers also said that Dreyfus had
a good memory and you know known for
having a good memory which was highly
suspicious right you know because a spy
has to remember a lot of things so case
went to trial and Dreyfus was found
guilty and afterwards they took him out
into this public square and
ritualistically tore his insignia from
his uniform and broke his sword into
this was called the degradation of
Dreyfus and they sentenced him to life
imprisonment on the aptly-named
Devil's Island which is this barren rock
off the coast of South America so there
he went and there he spent his days
alone writing letters and letters to the
French government begging them to reopen
his case so they could discover his
innocence but for the most part France
considered the matter closed so one
thing that's really interesting to me
about the Dreyfus Affair is this
question of why the officers were so
convinced that Dreyfus was guilty I mean
you might even assume that that they
were setting him up that they were
intentionally framing him but historians
don't think that's what happened as far
as we can tell the officers genuinely
believed that the case against Dreyfus
was strong
which you know makes you wonder what
does it say about the human mind that we
can find such paltry evidence to be
compelling enough to convict a man well
this is a case of what scientists call
motivated reasoning it's this phenomenon
in which our unconscious motivations our
desires and fears shape the way we
interpret information so some
information some ideas feel like our
allies and we want we want them to win
we want to defend them and other
information or ideas are the enemy and
we want to shoot them down so this is
why I call motivated reasoning soldier
mindset and probably most of you have
never persecuted a French Jewish officer
for high treason I assume but maybe
you've followed sports or politics so
you might have noticed that when the
referee judges that your team committed
a foul for example you're highly
motivated to find reasons why he's wrong
but if he judges that the other team
committed a foul awesome that's a good
call let's not examine it too closely or
maybe you've read an article or a study
that's examined some controversial
policy like capital punishment and as
researchers have demonstrated if if you
support capital punishment and the study
shows that it's not effective then
you're highly motivated to find all the
reasons why the study was poorly
designed but if it shows that capital
punishment works awesome it's a good
study and vice-versa if you don't
support capital punishment same thing
our judgment is just strongly influenced
unconsciously by which side we want to
win and this is ubiquitous the shapes
how we think about our health our
relationships how we decide how to vote
what we consider fair or ethical and now
what's most scary to me about motivated
reasoning or soldier mindset is how
unconscious it is you know we can think
we're being objective and fair-minded
and still wind up ruining the life of an
innocent man however fortunately for
Dreyfuss his story is not over
this is Colonel Picard he was another
high-ranking officer in the French army
and like most people he assumed Dreyfus
was guilty also like most people in the
Army he was at least casually
anti-semitic
but at a certain point the cart began to
suspect ah what if we're all wrong about
Dreyfus what happened was that he had
discovered evidence that the spying for
Germany had continued even after Dreyfus
was in prison and he had also discovered
that another officer in the army had
handwriting that perfectly matched the
memo much closer than Dreyfus his
handwriting so he brought these
discoveries to his superiors but to his
dismay they either didn't care or came
up with elaborate rationalizations to
explain his findings like well all
you've really shown the card is that
there's another spy who learned how to
mimic Dreyfus his handwriting and and he
you know picked up the torch of spying
after Dreyfus left my drive is still
guilty
eventually the cart managed to get
Dreyfus exonerated but it took him ten
years and for part of that time he
himself was in prison for the crime of
disloyalty to the army so you know a lot
of people feel like Picard can't really
be the hero of this story because he was
an anti-semite and that's bad which I
agree with but personally for me the
fact that Picard was anti-semitic
actually makes his actions more
admirable because he had the same
prejudices the same reasons to be biased
as his fellow officers but his
motivation to find the truth and uphold
it just trumped all of that so to me the
cart is a poster child for what I call
scout mindset it's the drive not to make
one idea win or another lose but just to
see what's really there as as honestly
and accurately as you can even if it's
not pretty or convenient or Pleasant and
this mindset is what I am personally
passionate about and what I've spent the
last few years examining and and trying
to figure out what causes scout mindset
you know why are some people sometimes
at least able to cut through their own
prejudices and biases and motivations
and just try to see the facts and the
evidence as objectively as they can and
the answer is emotional so
soldier minds that is rooted in emotions
like defensiveness or tribalism scout
mindset is - it's just rooted in
different emotions so for example Scouts
are curious they're more likely to say
that they feel pleasure when they learn
new information or an itch to solve a
puzzle they're more likely to feel
intrigued when they encounter something
that contradicts their expectations
Scouts also have different values
they're more likely to say that they
think it's virtuous to test your own
beliefs and they're less likely to say
that someone who changes his mind seems
weak and above all Scouts are grounded
which means that their self worth as a
person isn't tied to how right or wrong
they are about any particular topic so
you know they can believe that capital
punishment works and if studies come out
showing that it doesn't they can say huh
looks like I might be wrong doesn't mean
I'm bad or stupid you know so these
traits this cluster of traits is what
researchers have found and I've also
found anecdotally predicts good judgment
and the key takeaway I want to leave you
with about those traits is that they're
primarily not about how smart you are or
about how much you know in fact they
don't correlate very much with IQ at all
they're about how you feel so there's a
quote that I keep coming back to by
saint-exupéry
he's the author of the little prince and
he said if you want to build a ship
don't drum up your men to collect wood
and and give orders and distribute the
work instead teach them to yearn for the
vast and endless sea in other words I
claim if we want to really improve our
judgment as as individuals and as
society's what we need most is not more
instruction in logic or rhetoric or
probability or economics even though
those things are quite valuable but what
we most need to use those principles
well is scout mindset we need to change
the way we feel we need to learn how to
feel proud instead of ashamed
we notice we might have been wrong about
something we need to learn how to feel
intrigued
instead of defensive when we encounter
some information that contradicts our
beliefs so the question I want to leave
you with is what do you most yearn for
do you yearn to defend your own beliefs
or do you yearn to see the world as
clearly as you possibly can thank you